In the example in the quiz,
the math says the result should be 1.0.
But the code says 0.95.
That's a big difference.
Go ahead, replace the one
billion with just one, and
you'll see that the error becomes tiny.
We're going to want the values
involved in the calculation of this
big loss function that we care about
to never get too big or too small.
One good guiding principle
is that we always want our
variables to have zero mean and
equal variance whenever possible.
On top of the numeric issues,
there are also really good mathematical
reasons to keep values you compute.
Roughly around a mean of zero, an equal
variance when you're doing optimization.
A badly conditioned problem means
that the optimizer has to do
a lot of searching to go and
find a good solution.
A well conditioned problem
makes it a lot easier for
the optimizer to do its job.
If your dealing with images,
it's simple.
You can take the pixel values of your
image, they are typically between 0 and
255.
And simply subtract 128 and
divide by 128.
It doesn't change the content of your
image, but it makes it much easier for
the optimization to proceed numerically.
You also want your weights and
biases to be initialized at
a good enough starting point for
the gradient descent to proceed.
There are lots of fancy schemes to
find good initialization values, but
we're going to focus on a simple,
general method.
Draw the weights randomly from a
Gaussian distribution with mean zero and
standard deviation sigma.
The sigma value determines the order
of magnitude of your outputs
at the initial point
of your optimization.
Because of the soft max on top of it,
the order of magnitude
also determines the peakiness of your
initial probability distribution.
A large sigma means that your
distribution will have large peaks.
It's going to be very opinionated.
A small sigma means that your
distribution is very uncertain
about things.
It's usually better to begin with
an uncertain distribution and
let the optimization become more
confident as the train progress.
So use a small sigma to begin with.
Okay, so
now we actually have everything we need
to actually train this classifier.
We've got our training data, which
is normalized to have zero mean and
unit variance.
We multiply it by a large matrix, which
is initialized with random weights.
We apply the soft max and
then the cross entropy loss and
we calculate the average of this
loss over the entire training data.
Then our magical optimization
package computes
the derivative of this loss with respect
to the weights and to the biases and
takes a step back in the direction
opposite to that derivative.
And then we start all over again, and
repeat the process until we reach
a minimum of the loss function.